unterricht mit maske nordrhein westfalen
startet mit den bundesweit schärfsten
regeln ins neue schuljahr kandidatin für
die vize präsidentschaft kamen na herr
es zieht an der seite von joe biden für
die demokraten in den us-wahlkampf hitze
und unwetter lokale gewitter richten
schäden an bringen aber keine echte
abkühlung
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten am mittwoch den
sportarten arbeitnehmern in etwa 15
minuten 0 1 200 von mir
der schulstart in nordrhein westfalen
nach den sommerferien heute steht unter
besonderer beobachtung
zum einen weil das land mit den meisten
einwohnern auch bei den neuinfizierten
eine der höchsten raten hat zum anderen
weil nrw deshalb so scharfe vorkehrungen
trifft wie kein anderes bundesland so
hieß es heute für etwa zweieinhalb
millionen schülerinnen und schüler ab
ins klassenzimmer aber da gilt nun ab
klasse 5 maske auf wieder so klappte und
an kommt bei allen beteiligten berichten
torge bode und thaddäus parade
tja dann begrüßen wir euch ganz herzlich
zurück in diesem neuen schuljahr schönen
guten morgen zusammen
schulstart in klasse 7 im gymnasium am
geroweiher in mönchengladbach von einem
normalen schulbetrieb kann hier keine
rede sein
strenge verhaltensregeln und masken
pflicht im unterricht kann lernen und
lehren überhaupt funktionieren wenn die
gesichtsmimik kaum noch erkennbar ist
skepsis beim schulleiter
also ich finde es kritisch und zwar aus
pädagogischen gründen
ich habe so ein bisschen die bedenken
dass eben die beziehung sehr stark
darunter leidet wenn ich unterrichte
dann muss ich sehen ist das was ich
gesagt habe ist dass angekommen auch
schülerinnen und schüler reagieren mit
gemischten gefühlen
dann kommt halt noch schlechter luft das
ist schon nervig aber ich weiß dass das
ist damit das mit krone endlich aufhören
also ich das ganze schuljahr aushalten
mit der masken pflicht im unterricht
beschreitet nordrhein westfalen einen
bundesweiten sonderweg eine reine
vorsichtsmaßnahme sagt die nrw
schulministerin glaube schon dass wir im
gegensatz zu anderen bundesländern hier
bei uns in nordrhein westfalen einen
namen höheres infektionsgeschehen gerade
in den vergangenen tagen verzeichnen
mussten
und hier geht es dann um die sicherheit
um die unversehrtheit unserer
schülerinnen und schüler aber natürlich
auch unsere lehrkräfte doch gerade von
denen kommt kritik sieht vermissen ein
schlüssiges gesamtkonzept die massen
pflicht ist geschuldet dass wir mit vier
klassen in die schulen geht
sie ist sicherlich schwierig pädagogisch
auch nicht richtig wir hätten gefordert
mehr abstand in den klassen zu halten
also kleine klassen zu beginn das wäre
der richtige weg gewesen
die masken pflicht im unterricht ist
zunächst bis ende august befristet
sollten die infektionszahlen weiter
steigen ist eine verlängerung nicht
ausgeschlossen
die zahl der neuinfektionen in
deutschland steigt weiter
das robert koch institut meldet 1226
neue corona fälle innerhalb eines tages
dann ist der höchste wert seit anfang
mai
die bundesregierung ist besorgt
gesundheitsminister sparen mahnte jetzt
sehr wachsam zu sein
christoph distel berichtet deutschland
im august der mensch heißt das virus
reist mit im flugzeug im auto oder im
zug viele der neuen fälle hierzulande
gehen auf ansteckungen im ausland zurück
31 prozent sagt das robert-koch-institut
wobei die spur vor allem nach
südosteuropa oder spanien führe
gleichzeitig steigt auch zu hause das
risiko weil so viele genug haben von
abstand und maske zusammengenommen
alarmiert dass virologen und regierung
gleichermaßen
wir haben nicht das eine große
infektions ereignissen wir haben viele
kleine und mittlere ausbrüche im ganzen
land wenn wir jetzt nicht alle aufpassen
und was dann sind dann kann dieses
geschehen noch eine ganz eigene dynamik
entfalten im wochenschnitt ist die zahl
der infektionen auf 960 pro tag
gestiegen dabei grassiert das virus
besonders dicht im westen der republik
da wo am meisten und tiefsten orange ist
in hessen und nordrhein westfalen etwa
melden durchweg alle landkreise neue
fälle also mit voller kraft gegen
steuern entschied jetzt die
nrw-landesregierung 150 euro bußgeld
will sie von jedem masken verweigerer in
bus oder bahn ohne vorwarnung ohne
pardon
stellt sich nur die frage wer soll das
kassieren das ist natürlich eine aufgabe
die liegen bei polizei und
ordnungsämtern
die sind jetzt personell vermutlich auch
nicht so umfangreich aufgestellt dass
sie das überall und jederzeit
entsprechend durchsetzen können wir als
verkehrsunternehmen dürfen das nicht das
ist rechtlich nicht möglich dass man
eine ordnungswidrigkeit als unternehmen
verkehrsunternehmen durchsetzt ein
saftiges bußgeld aber kaum gefahr
erwischt zu werden so dürfte dem virus
schwer beizukommen sein
bleibt also angesichts der steigenden
fallzahlen vor allem eins der immer
wieder neue appell an die vernunft und
rücksicht aller im kampf gegen korona
ist das hier keine gute nachricht in
bayern hat es eine massive panne gegeben
seit wochen werden dort reiserückkehrer
getestet jetzt kam raus bei 900 menschen
wurde corona nachgewiesen sie haben aber
ihr testergebnis nicht bekommen
es gab probleme bei der übermittlung so
das bayerische gesundheitsministerium
insgesamt warten 44.000 menschen noch
immer auf ihr testergebnis auch
vielerorts im ausland steigen die korona
zahlen das auswärtige amt hat seine
reisewarnung für teile spaniens auf die
hauptstadt madrid und das baskenland
ausgedehnt dort gebe es erneut hohe
infektionszahlen von mehr als 50 fällen
auf 100000 einwohner innerhalb von
sieben tagen
damit gilt jetzt für fünf spanische
regionen eine reisewarnung neben madrid
und dem baskenland sind das navarra
aragon und katalonien zum us
präsidentschaftswahlkampf sie sei so
wirklich eine furchtlose kämpferin für
die einfachen leute
so begründete joe biden seine
entscheidung für kamera harris als vize
kandidatin und die wahl ist historisch
mit ihr könnte erstmals eine schwarze
frau als vize-präsidentin ins weiße haus
einziehen
im vorwahlkampf noch konkurrentin von
beiden ist die senatorin aus kalifornien
jetzt seine hoffnungsträgerin im duell
gegen us präsident ab ines trams bist du
bereit an die arbeit zu gehen fragt joe
biden kamalla harris corona bedingt per
video-konferenz monate hatte er
gespräche geführt mit elf an wärterinnen
sie nun soll seine vize kandidatin
werden ist die antwort ja fragt er
absolut ja sagt sie ich bin bereit das
mit dir und für dich zu tun ich bin
zutiefst geehrt und sehr aufgeregt
kambala harris senatorin aus kalifornien
eine krankenversicherung für alle will
sie mehr grüne energie einen höheren
mindestlohn progressive ziele für die
moderaten in ihrer partei aber nicht zu
links wer sind wir wie wollen wir als
amerikaner sein
wir sollten diese frage der welt
beantworten und auf uns selber amerika
wir sind besser als dies hier als
tochter einer mutter aus indien und
eines vaters aus jamaika wuchs sie auf
ihre karriere beginnt harris als
staatsanwältin das verfolgt sie linke
aktivisten sehen bis heute nur die
polizistin in ihr als senatorin machte
sich einen namen als angriffslustige
fragerin in den ausschüssen auch joe
biden attackiert sie als sie selber noch
für die präsidentschaft kandidiert er
habe vor jahrzehnten mit senatoren
zusammen gearbeitet die die
rassentrennung befürworteten sie selbst
wäre damals betroffen gewesen
die trump kampagne skizziert harris
umgehend als radikal links am nennt sie
garstig sie war die gemeinste die
schrecklichste und respektlose und dazu
wohl die liberalste person im senat
harris könnte geschichte schreiben eine
schwarze frau
als vize-präsidentin die frage bleibt
ist amerika dazu bereit
da fragen wir unseren usa
korrespondentin elmar theveßen elmer hat
beiden mit kamera harris größere chancen
ich glaube ja nach meinungsumfragen
wissen wir dass über 70 prozent der
amerikaner der meinung sind dass das
land ein rassismus problem hat und dass
sich da dringend etwas ändern muss und
insofern ist eine kandidatin mit dem
hintergrund von camilla harris eine die
besonders glaubwürdig auch rüber kommt
diese veränderung herbeizuführen
die beiden wollen noch viel mehr sie
wollen auch wirtschaftliche und soziale
veränderungen und das kann natürlich
dazu führen dass auch amerikaner angst
bekommen vor zu viel veränderung da sind
dann eben donald trump und mike pence
die ein amerika amerika anbieten dem es
wirtschaftlich besser geht aber bei dem
sich nicht so wahnsinnig viel verändern
soll und deswegen könnte es dann bei der
wahl im november noch mal sehr spannend
werden hat die entscheidung beiden es
auch deshalb solche bedeutung weil eine
vize-präsidentin eben immer auch eine
mögliche präsidentin ist ja ich glaube
das ist so das wird eine große rolle
spielen es wäre die erste frau als
präsidentin der usa
ich glaube das ist absolut vorstellbar
wir haben hier in den usa 9 gouverneur
innen die einen guten job machen 26
senatorinnen im kongress wir haben in
anderen ländern regierungs und
staatschefs
ich glaube da kommen die wähler ins
grübeln es gibt daher in diesem land
auch eine große sehnsucht nach einem
ende der polarisierung und da ertappen
sich sicher auch viele bei dem gedanken
was eine frau im höchsten staatsamt
anders machen würde als donald trump der
starke frauen wir haben es vorhin gehört
ja als gemein garstig und fies
bezeichnet also insofern kann auch das
bei der wahl im november eine ganz
herausragende rolle spielt vielen dank
elmar theveßen
wenn sie mehr über die designierte vize
kandidatin von joe biden erfahren wollen
empfehlen wir ihnen unsere zdf heute app
dort finden sie auch ein video porträt
von kamera harris nach beirut wo die wut
auf die regierung weiter an
hält obwohl die ja schon zurückgetreten
ist aber die herrschende klasse wird
verantwortlich gemacht für die 170 toten
und mehr als 6.000 verletzten der
explosionskatastrophe in hafen vor allem
wegen ihrer korruptheit auch
außenminister maß drängte bei seinem
besuch im libanon heute auf einen
politischen wandel des landes liegt
weiter das maß an zerstörung so der
außenminister in beirut sei für menschen
die in deutschland lebten nahezu
unvorstellbar was dankte den
rettungshelfern auch dem technischen
hilfswerk für ihren einsatz und sicherte
die unterstützung deutschlands zu im
moment weil wir erst einmal helfen das
leid der menschen hierher zu lindern und
dafür zu sorgen dass hier all das was
zerstört ist so schnell wie möglich
wieder aufgebaut wird
eine anwohnerin schilderte in
verzweifelten worten wie sie selbst und
ihre nachbarn jetzt ohne wohnung um ihre
existenz kämpfen müssten
schuld daran sei eine korrupte politiker
kaste die sich selbst bereichere die
haben uns alles genommen unser geld
unsere harte arbeitete zukunft alles das
land brauche dringend tiefgreifende
politische und wirtschaftliche reformen
so maaß ein weiter so könne es nicht
geben
das wird die aufgabe der zukunft sein
das vertrauen der bürgerinnen und bürger
im libanon zurück zu bringen und dafür
muss die politische elite in diesem land
umdenken und zwar ganz erheblich eine
forderung die maß auch gegenüber
staatspräsidenten geäußert haben dürfte
bislang ließ der 85 jährige ex general
der seit über vier jahrzehnten
spitzenämter im libanon bekleidet wenig
bereitschaft zu reformen erkennen
auch eine woche nach der
explosionskatastrophe sind die bürger in
beruht weitgehend auf sich selbst und
auf hilfsorganisationen angewiesen
wirksame unterstützung kann der
weitgehend zahlungsunfähige start kaum
leisten
seit monaten haben wir nichts mehr zu
essen ich weiß nicht wie ich meine
kinder satt kriegen soll
mein mann hat seine arbeit verloren es
ist beschämend und erniedrigend so
ungerecht
nach schätzungen der vereinten nationen
lebt inzwischen fast die hälfte der
libanesen an der armutsgrenze
uli gack ist in beirut uli wie
realistisch ist denn die hoffnung auf
veränderung im libanon nach solange die
politische eliten haufen geld mit diesem
system verdient eigentlich eher wenig
die bundes die delegation heute hat bei
dem staatspräsident eine gewisse eine
gewisse realitätsferne festgestellt und
hat auch gesagt er hätte den schrei der
straße möglicherweise nicht gehört das
ganze elend liegt im proporzsystem das
lieb und gut gemeint nach dem
bürgerkrieg in dem alle politischen und
religiösen gruppen an der macht
teilhaben sollen können aber es gab eben
keine parlamentarische kontrolle dieser
webfehler rächt sich heute jeder deren
amt hat bedient sich selbst und seine
politische klientel das land selbst geht
dabei den bach runter und radikal
islamistische organisationen wie die
hisbollah vom iran ferngesteuert während
sich hier als der staat im staate der
symbol dieses gesamten niedergangs
könnte die explosion der vergangenen
woche seien fast alle haben gewusst dass
da unten fast 30.000 tonnen
hochbrisantes material liegen aber weil
sie sich mit diesem zeug eben nicht auf
die schnelle viel reibach machen ließ
und sie das aus hat sich niemand darum
gekümmert das resultat ist bekannt
vielen dank für die einschätzung kolleg
war das in beirut nach der wahl in
belarus nimmt die gewalt zu die polizei
ist in der vergangenen nacht wieder hart
gegen die demonstranten vorgegangen
in 25 städten hier in der hauptstadt
minsk protestierten wieder viele
menschen gegen präsident lukaschenko
sie werfen ihm massiven wahlbetrug vor
die polizei brachte viele demonstranten
ins gefängnis in den vergangenen tagen
wurden insgesamt bereits mehr als 6.000
regierungskritiker festgenommen
im nordosten von schottland ist ein
passagierzug entgleist mindestens drei
menschen starben
sechs weitere wurden verletzt
der zug war unterwegs von aberdeen nach
glasgow
noch haben die behörden keine angaben
dazu gemacht warum er entlaste es hatte
aber in der gegend zuvor heftigen regen
und überschwemmungen gegeben
das wetter hier bei uns und zurück nach
deutschland und zum wetter bei uns das
bleibt unverändert
hitze und tropische nächte und immer
wieder unwetter besonders im westen
heiko pisa beginnt sein bericht in
rheinland pfalz es war nur gut eine
viertelstunde die der kleine ort beiden
von sturm und regen massen getroffen
wurde
die folgen zeigen sich am morgen danach
dächer abgedeckt bäume im wald
abgeknickt die kirchturmspitze verbogen
die gewitter die wandern sehr langsam
und haben also sehr viel zeit sich zu
entwickeln und sehr viel regen ab zu
lassen und dann kommt es in großen
mengen es ist sehr heiss es gibt sehr
viele energien lüfte und dadurch werden
diese gewitter sehr heftig in der
letzten nacht waren die unwetter auch
über nrw gezogen überstunden entluden
sich immer wieder heftige gewitter
autobahnen wie hier bei neuss wurden
überflutet keller liefen voll bis zu
einem halben meter hoch stand das wasser
dort auch heute wieder heftige gewitter
in thüringen bei erfurt trifft es die a4
plötzlich aquaplaninggefahr und
schlechte sicht
die gewitter ziehen weiter richtung
nordosten und sind weiterhin
unwetterartig also platz regen sturm und
hagel all das ist dabei und auch die
hitze die wandert mit den gewittern
richtung nordosten
und dann kann es auch in berlin
ungemütlich werden zumindest heute lässt
sich dort das sommerwetter noch ganz
unbeschwert genießen
und jetzt zum sport und zur arbeit und
zur heute abend beginn der finalrunde in
lissabon bergamo trifft auf paris st
germain alle viertel und halbfinals
sowie das endspiel in einer stadt ein ko
turnier ohne publikum
ja und das in einer stadt so was von
fußball begeistert ist
stell dir vor es ist champions league
und keiner geht hin für die menschen in
lissabon ist fußball ganz nah und doch
weit weg
ich weiß dass können hier fängt ein aber
man spürt nichts davon
man merkt nicht viel davon wegen der
pandemie alle finalspiele in einer stadt
und in ihren stadien und über allem die
hoffnung dass es gut geht
ich glaube dass das gerade jetzt wenn
denn die mannschaften auch noch nach
portugal reisen die der davor denn
getestet werden und dann glaube ich
nicht dass ich während des turniers da
jetzt noch jemand infiziert für die
gastgeber es dass geister turnier ein
hoffnungsschimmer für sicheren tourismus
die infektionszahlen sinken derzeit
lissabon testet viel und verfolgt die
fälle
das turnier ist anerkennung der qualität
unserer organisation ins regal
kurz vor anpfiff doch einige fans aus
bergamo einer stadt die sehr stark unter
geholt die russische regierung will eine
5 millionen euro geldstrafe übernehmen
die im zuge des doping und betrug
skandals vom internationalen
leichtathletikverband verhängt worden
war
ansonsten hätte russland einen
ausschluss aus dem weltverband gedroht
und eine teilnahme russische athleten an
den olympischen spielen in tokio 2021
wäre äußerst fraglich gewesen
start der dauphiné rundfahrt in
frankreich sozusagen die generalprobe
für die tour de france in zweieinhalb
wochen 218,5 kilometer im französischen
zentralmassiv die erste von fünf etappen
insgesamt ein anspruchsvoller formcheck
für die radprofis gewonnen hat laut fall
art belgien vor der em-pause afrika und
tour-de-france-sieger eh ganz banal
kolumbien bester deutscher emanuel
buchmann als sechzehnter möchte der
klickt nicht so prickelnd ist ein
richtig richtig gutes ergebnis schauen
wir mal wie das ergebnis beim lotto ist
hier sind die zahlen 4 20 21 34 35 45
und die superzahl 4
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf
seite 55 7
und jetzt haben wir noch eine kleine
korrektur unser korrespondent sprach
daraufhin von 30.000 tonnen exklusiven
material sind tatsächlich sind es knapp
3000 gewesen wir bitten um
entschuldigung
nochmal zum wetter jetzt da gibt es eine
unwetterwarnung für teile von nordrhein
westfalen und auch morgen sind gewitter
zu erwarten
die details hat gleich ist intelli das
war es von uns danke für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
im heute journal bringt sie claus kleber
später auf den neuesten stand und her
freut sich ab morgen christian sievers
auf sie noch einen entspannten abend
wünschen burgess
[Musik]
ein schöner abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter bisher waren die
tiefs relativ schwach die uns die warme
luft aus dem südwesten gebracht haben
und diese ski für das ist etwas
kräftiger lenkt auch warme luft zu uns
aber die ist feucht und so gibt es
morgen kräftige gewitter schauen wir
erstmal in die nacht und da wird es
gewitter an in den nächsten stunden
teilweise heftig mit platzregen
sturmböen und hagel
nach osten und norden hin ist es eher
trocken an der nordsee weht ein
kräftiger ostwind temperaturen sinken
gerade mal auf 22 grad im westen hier
richtung rhein main gebiet ist eine
tropische nacht und das verbreitet im
westen 14 grad wird es richtung
nordosten
morgen im tagesverlauf setzten sich die
gewitter weiter richtung mitte durch
oder auch im süden kracht es ansonsten
sonnenschein nach norden und das bei
hohen temperaturen wieder bis 35 grad im
osten deutschlands im südwesten nicht
mehr so heiß bis 31 grad
die hitze bleibt uns verhalten aber
wandert richtung osten im westen kühlt
es weiter ab 22 bis 34 grad am freitag
und heftige gewitter und auch am samstag
sieht es so ähnlich aus ein schöner
abend